now i'm super interested in what
constitutes a religion and what doesn't
which is why i have many questions about
this sure the people who
label what you just outlined as woo
this stigmatization
is there something that is common among
those people that makes the
stigmatization itself a form of religion
so that is to say when the people who
are of the more atheistic type not
picking on them it's just the easiest
that come to mind when the atheistic
types make fun of religion and they say
that i'm not religious is there
something religious about that
oh i hear what you're saying um
no i don't necessarily think so i know
that a lot of people say that atheism is
like a religion because you know people
are
you know either you are you aren't
atheist and you know you're in your
community and it's kind of exclusionary
right and some religions are like that
not all but some are
and
um they're dogmatic like they're
dogmatic atheists i think that's what
they're trying to say is there's a
dogmatism about
some atheists
who like i said like to put like to make
a strong man argument about religion and
then like knock it down and say see
there's nothing there right um
yeah i don't think so i think that um
there's a variety of atheist beliefs
anyway right so when i say i was atheist
with respect to ufos
i didn't believe in the objective
reality of it of ufos okay um and i
thought that people who did i thought
they were completely wrong
and i'm not that way anymore so you can
be atheist about some things and not
atheist about other things with respect
to god okay um some religions are are
atheists
there are some atheistic religions